well the one thing i know about the
liberal party is versus the
conservatives any military guy will know
if you vote the liberal party in you're
going to get cuts to funding
uh last time they had uh creighton's
government in it was so bad that there
were service people people doing food
stamps
and harper's government came in they
obviously increased funding meet our
nato commitments
so for that reason alone any military
guy who doesn't vote conservative is
kind of weird
for me and it's something i really
wanted to ask him
it's like uh you know how most canadians
do strategic voting right we don't
actually vote for anybody we vote
against them yeah yeah yeah and that's a
really good point actually i've got a
i've got a map here that i wanted to
present to him when
um
we were going to go live so i'll throw
it up on the screen because i think this
is going to illustrate the point that
you want to make because it's like you
know
yeah
so i just pulled up like a normal
writing so i just you know got something
in the gta we got richmond hill here
and
red is of course liberal and green is
conservative and they flip flop back and
forth over the years it's mostly been a
liberal riding i think there's 339
ridings in canada so there's that many
seats that are available in parliament
from representatives for the federal
government and of course you know if
you're right if if you represent
enough seats to become the majority then
then your leader becomes the prime
minister basically is the way that it
works here
so it's it's probably a similar system
to what way it is in the us but you know
here we got
the liberals and the conservatives
flip-flopping back and forth over the
years with very little mention of the
other parties with the exception of down
over here if i scroll down a bit more i
can see the people's representative igor
as 507 votes so let's say you like
max bernier and you'd like him to be the
prime minister of canada because you
stand you know for what he stands for
voting for the people's party like would
that make sense if if it's a flip-flop
between the conservatives and the
liberals
if you're voting for what you want sure
but that's the thing let's say you
really hate the lockdown policies and
trudeau just went on didn't he just do a
whole speech basically saying yeah half
the canadians are going to get screwed
over on this one screw those guys and
everybody's cheering them on yeah you
call them you know those people over
there are putting our children at risk
oh yeah remember when john don cherry
got fired for saying those people yeah
my how times have changed times have
changed haven't i want to vote for him
and if he gets like was it one seat and
five percent of the popular vote he gets
a seat at the the debate table right i
think that's how it works yeah
so how can somebody well
well the riding has to elect the
representative to go to ottawa
right and last election they got no
seats yeah right because the green
party's barely better than them and they
always get a seat because they elizabeth
may wins her one seat in hippie town
right
but then yeah how do you tell a guy like
look you're in a writing like that where
literally
you can choose to vote for you want to
and then get what you don't want you'll
get like a liberal vaccine pass thing
but you vote for maxine bernier
or you can vote for the conservatives
and hopefully lose one more seat for the
liberal party right that's strategic
voting and i'm like
why is he putting a candidate in that
riding and if so why would somebody vote
for that because i think ppc is mostly a
conservative party it's for like the old
harper type
conservatives that have kind of been
disenfranchised with the new party if i
understand it correctly yeah the way i
understand it is is it somewhere between
classical liberal and like libertarian
conservative it's like a mashup of all
of that is the way they've been
labeled
like for me it's great here it's like
the liberals are two to one
for votes so yeah well you live downtown
toronto man you're right in the core
you're the worst part is that i'm not
even a conservative i've i voted ndp so
often because i do really
i want them as the opposition party
they're a terrible party dude like wow
so i was saying earlier like i don't
know if you were watching when i was
talking about jagmeet but he was he was
a critic that was assigned to bill 55 in
2011 when i was lobbying the
ontario government and and i think he
was a um
bradford writing a guy or brantford i
don't know anyway he was you know he was
the elected official there for
ontario and he was a critic on the bill
so whenever a bill is presented to to
parliament each of the parley's parties
will assign a critic to it to basically
say all right you know
collect the information they pass it on
to the party and then when it gets voted
to go to royal ascent if it passes or
not then it becomes law sort of thing so
he was the guy that i was working with
and there was one other ndp guy that i
work with that i that i had to buy lunch
to meet with him so my lobby said you
know we can meet with this guy but you
can only do a lunch we'll meet in this
restaurant you know we sit down i buy
this guy a hundred dollar steak and i'm
listening to him go on and on about how
much he loves his boat and his fast car
and i'm like this dude's an ndp
representative and all he's talking
about is blowing money on fast and
he's eating a steak i'm buying and he
did nothing
but like he didn't want to listen to
what i what i needed to talk to him
about he just wanted to talk about his
hobbies right i can't remember the name
his name for the life of me
but
jack meek singh at least seem like a
smart guy right like he's like he's an
intelligent guy he's a lawyer
um he assured me that he was going to do
what was right for
the consumer
and the way the legislation of the law
was written it was very hostile towards
the consumer it would
remove the option of debt relief or make
it much more expensive
um and
lo and behold the bill got passed and it
went through royal ascendant became law
and all the parties pretty much agreed
on it
the only
the only critic that i didn't feel like
i was misled by at the time that i met
with was the conservative critic
right which makes sense don't get me
wrong though what i said i voted ndp
that was during like the layton era
you guys oh jack layton was like by a
lot of people yeah basically it's like
the ndp is always a horrible party that
has like a leader that everybody likes
that's the only way they get votes
i'm with you on that it's just
i don't want to be a conservative i
don't want to be a liberal i don't think
they're like the states anyway where
they have democrats republicans ours are
both business friendly it's more of like
a east coast versus west coast thing
one of the one of the big problems that
isn't getting
air time right now i mean the air time
is is either
people yelling at trudeau when he's
going to and from his tour bus like
they're calling them
right-wing protesters but they're really
just you know probably trudeau voters
that were pissed off because they got
misled it was those people those people
over there
and um you know the topic of the
vaccination the beer bug if you don't do
it you know we're gonna force you to do
it blah blah blah sort of thing but
one thing i've noticed in the last two
years since all of these
imposed laws on canadians is i've got
about
i mean i can count them on two hands
maybe two hands in a foot friends that
have just said you know what i'm done
with it
they bend me over and they tax me at 53
i'm paying way too much money into
programs that i don't agree with i run a
business that's location independent i
can go anywhere and they just packed up
their bags and left canada you know they
sold all of their
packed up their bags and they've either
gone to caribbean islands mexico
uh u.s states that have lower tax rates
you know that are more friendlier um
that's the cayman islands for canada
yeah like where are they gonna get the
tax revenue when all of the
entrepreneurs that are chasing
excellence putting a dent in the
universe say you know what i don't need
to live here well that's that's been the
canadian thing even as far back as the
80s when i was a kid the saying was
canada cuts down the tall trees right
and the only way to make it as a
canadian is to go is to become an
american
that's why all of us are just actors
everybody is the only guy
like they move down there
it's not just taxes either it's the
whole thing
it's just nothing is encouraged there's
no investment montreal even tried like
tech sector investment to get like our
version of silicon valley but
it turned into such like a mafia grip
we're just we're just very bad at the
entrepreneurial spirit
like we got good people just bad
policies surrounding it
you